it shouldn't surprise you that when the
american civil war broke out it was
pretty big news all over the world
but how did the rest of the world react
to the american civil war
and did they plan to do anything about
it so before starting it's important to
know that the usa wasn't seen by many of
the world's nations at this time as a
major player
a rising star for certain but the usa
wasn't seen as being equal to europe's
great powers
not even austria as such many leaders
saw the american civil war as being a
bit of a sideshow to events in europe at
the time like the wars in the italian
peninsula or that time
the danish provoked prussia into a war
europe's major players sent observers to
the usa to see what tactics and
technologies were being used and they
were
frankly not impressed with the quality
of warring going on as for reaction
starting with the usa's neighbor to the
south mexico its government's initial
reaction was one of awkward silence
it had just finished its own civil war
and due to its previous war with the usa
there was no love lost not that it had
much time to think about it since in
late 1861 the french invaded and so
they'd spend the rest of the war having
their own problems
as for the north canada was a series of
british imperial domains at this point
and as such its foreign policy was
determined in london
that said the people of canada were
firmly in the camp of the union and many
thousands of volunteers went south to
fight against the confederacy
whereas to the british the american
civil war was seen as a surprise and one
which complicated britain's foreign
policy
you see britain imported a lot of cotton
from the now confederate states and
given that many parts of the country
financially depended on them the british
were keen to see the war end quickly for
economic reasons
now this didn't have to be a union win
and british shipyards produced several
warships of the confederate states
the confederacy hoped that britain would
recognize its independence which would
likely lead france to do the same and
would strengthen its position
diplomatically
britain never did this though because it
didn't want the united states to invade
canada
wars were expensive and the overwhelming
majority of the british public supported
the union
especially when the cause of the war
moved from restoring the union to
abolishing slavery and over the years
many many thousands of people living in
the british isles overwhelmingly irish
went to the us to fight for the union
thus the confederacy got little help as
for the french its reaction was the same
as the austrians
that these developments were a welcome
surprise it allowed franco-austrian
intervention in mexico so that
maximilian habsburg could be placed on
the throne there to increase their
influence in the new world
and also to give back the money that
mexico was refusing to pay its creditors
both nations had unofficial contact with
the confederacy over mutual recognition
yet neither france nor austria did
anything because they knew it would mean
war with the united states
whereas prussia's reaction to the
outbreak of the civil war wasn't one of
shock but that it brought with it
opportunity
despite being disappointed with the
quality of their troops and tactics
prussia favored the union
prussia was itself a very conservative
state but its leadership knew that
acting against the union would
negatively impact its image amongst the
very pro-union german-speaking world
which as you know it was trying to unite
and so by pushing itself as a firm alloy
of abolitionism and the union prussia's
image amongst the german-speaking world
could be improved with very little
effort and what about russia
american leadership was bolstered by a
large russian fleet sailing to their
coast which they hoped would help them
blockade the confederacy but fun fact
no the fleet was actually there to stop
itself from being caged up in the baltic
sea in case of war with britain
as tensions between the two were high
tsar alexander ii was an outspoken ally
of lincoln and pushed for the total
destruction of the confederacy
and as for the ottoman reaction they
were overwhelmingly pro-union
they signed a trade deal with the union
banned confederate ships from their
waters and also
made a ton of money since they were the
second best source of cotton for
european markets and their main
competitor had just been blockaded
all in all the world's reaction to the
outbreak of the civil war was one of
initial surprise followed by it asking
itself
how can this benefit me i hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with a special thanks to my
patrons
james bissonette sam kelly moneymaker
the pastry section danny maloney moe
marvin cassell rob waterhouse james
castaneda jordan longley spinning three
plates gustav swan jerry lamdin rasheed
ali marcus asner izzy maggie paxkowski
cooling castleman david silverman
coppertone anthony beckett matthew
shipley
lexi schwinn robert wetzel skye
chappelle winston cayward aaron the
white spencer lightfoot and fobo joe